Okay Josh do you want to see something cool?
Yeah!
Okay, so I'm gonna light this candle
and what should happen is the wick burns...
And what happens now?
It will melt?
See, it melts
Oh yeah you're right so once
it's got a little wax around I'm going
to blow it out and I want you to watch
very very carefully
After 3.
1...2...3
You didn't touch it! That's right I didn't touch it!
Candles are made of wax. When you light
the wick the heat melts the wax and
turns it into a liquid. This liquid is
drawn up through the wick.
As it travels up the wick the liquid gets hotter and
evaporates. It turns into a gas
The gas mixes with the oxygen in the air and
catches fire from the original flame
Once this happens the candle flame comes
from the burning wax gas not the burning wick.
When you blow out the
candle the wick stays hot for a while so
the wax continues to evaporate.
This means there's still some gas above the wick.
So when you bring a flame close to
the wick this gas catches fire and relights the candle
Okay Josh now I've
got a jar here I'm going to put it over
the top of the candle what do you think
will happen?
It'll go out. It will go out
Why do you think it would go out? Because the air doesn't come in
I wonder how long it will take for it to
go out? Immediately! Immediately okay well
let's have a go.
A candle flame is a
result of a chemical reaction between
the gas from the wax and the oxygen in
the air when you trap a candle under a
jar it only has a limited amount of
oxygen. When that runs out the candle
can't burn anymore so the flame goes out.
Do you think it changes if I change the
size of the jar? Yeah.
Let's have a go
It takes a longer time! That's interesting
And it goes out slower
Should we have a go with a
bigger jar? Yeah!
Do you think we can time it?
Yeah!
Science experiments often involve
changing one thing and seeing what
happens. We can learn about the world
just by looking at things but scientists
usually go beyond just looking and
measure things
Measurements help describe things more
precisely and make scientific results
more useful
To find out more about this
activity check out the worksheet and
remember you can subscribe to more great
experiments and don't forget to send us
your photos and your videos
That is so cool!